so zu einer entscheidung gekommen
nummer 3 bekommt von uns die fünf weil
das alles nun ist ganz knackig ist ich
habe vor einigen tagen hier auf meinem
kanal ein video bei dem fernseh serie
namens hot five gemacht die ich extrem
abstoßen fahren und im nach des videos
kam viele kommentare von euch die
entweder in die richtung gehen
was ist das für ein unsinn oder die
richtung ging sebastian es gibt auch
noch eine männer edition von hotfile
schau dir die auch mal an und dann habe
ich mir gedacht heute will ich natürlich
nicht so sein also diesmal sitzen frauen
in der jury und machen männer fertig die
folgen stehen so viel dazu leute schauen
was man die männer an die heute
beurteilt werden
22 jahre patrick 21 pascal 24 wir sehen
auf jeden fall da prosieben schon wieder
wirklich heiße auswahl also was ich euch
sagen wir leute ist warum sie die schon
wieder ausgegraben real tat hat er den
hatte diesen bart gesehen sind das
ägyptische ruhen in deinem alter was ist
das uns ist die selbsteinschätzung der
jungs nicht genug deshalb urteil zudem
eine attraktive jury über die männer und
vier kategorien aussehen sensibilität
und outfit
diese kategorien schon wieder outfit pro
was war das dritte sensibilität
sensibilität okay also aussehen pole
outfit kann ich irgendwie noch halbwegs
nachvollziehen dass man das irgendwie
von außen testen kann
aber wir wollen die sensibilität testen
weil sie die beleidigen und gucken wie
weit diese alexandra 32 jahre alt 23 ja
also wir uns schon zu erkennen dass
leute sind bei dieser männer edition
tatsächlich die rollen jetzt umgedreht
davor war es ja die frauen die quasi
beurteilt wurden und die männer waren in
syrien standen folgen haben welche
sprüche raus gelassen
ich muss sagen so wie diese frauen jury
sich jetzt gerade hier schon präsentiert
traust ihn auf jeden fall zu dass sie
auch auf einem level von abstoßend sein
mit der männer die aus den letzten
videos sein können ganz wichtiger
indikator ist schon mal da hier leute
jemand der sich so irgendwohin steht
egal wo dann kann man schon mal sehen
nicht vertrauen
okay das geht also auch weiter ich hab
im letzten video was mich wirklich echt
krass aufgeregt hat ja auch schon
kritisiert dass da die rede von
knackigen frauen waren so ich habe da
immer den vergleich verwendet das man
halt normalerweise über würstchen
spricht dass die knackig center
bockwürste der industrie bratwürste wird
er war widersprach gebrauchte dir eins
zu eins weiter jetzt ist ja nicht die
rede von knackigen deutschländer
würstchen ak frauen in deutschland
eigentlich deutschland macht sondern von
schnitten
[Gelächter]
was frischfleisch also was hat die jury
denn davor so was haben das haben die
frauen mit den jungs vor
das ist ein podcasting oder wie ich also
verstehe nicht ganz warum sie jetzt hier
das wort frischfleisch verwendet sag mal
was genau was sie mit den jungs vor also
ich muss sagen ich hab natürlich ganz
klaren favoriten also der eine typ mit
diesem genre käsen schnitt der ist auch
schon relativ steilen unterwegs ist auch
kann man nichts sagen es schon stabil
aber mein favorit dass es auf jeden fall
der mit dem hörer griffen bad also der
der sie irgendwelche ägyptischen antiken
schriften in bahrain rasieren lassen
hatte ich meine das ist ein level an
commitment das muss auch erst mal
belohnt werden also ohne wird ich weiß
nicht was das soll
ich weiß nicht was das soll es wieder
diese situation jetzt gerade im gesehen
wollte die jury sitzt hier drei meter
nach vorne stehen die kandidaten die
guard beurteilt werden und die schnaken
irgendwie scheiße darüber dass ihm ja
hoffentlich nicht die badehose runter
hat folgendes kam von der 32-jährigen
das ist etwas was ich so bei 14 jährigen
erwarten würde die noch nie im leben ihr
wisst schon was ich meine
die könnte überhaupt nicht klar wie es
anders aus also da wirklich der spaß bei
mir aufhörte okay also man kann
natürlich sagen ja hat fünf ist eine
oberflächliche sendung aber dass die
vermittelten die falsche werte schön und
gut aber wenn ein bruder von mir da
reingeht mit hieroglyphen bad und dann
auf platz fünf kommt beim aussäen
dann läuft irgendwas schief diesen
wirklich besoffene haben jetzt einen
irokesen typen auf platz 2 gepackt sagt
mal sagen eure meinung was haltet ihr
davon
was sagt zu dieser friese also ich weiß
nicht in welchem jahr dieser beitrag
gedreht wurde aber es kann nicht in den
letzten tausend jahren gewinn
runde zwei der proben jetzt stehen die
zwei backen im fokus des interesses fünf
hinter müssen in die richtige
reihenfolge gebracht werden
[Musik]
das ist unsere fernsehen in deutschland
leute das ist unser fernsehen in
deutschland das ist das was unsere
kinder sich rein ziehen oder zumindest
mal angezogen haben wenn sie von der
schule nach hause kommen und einfach ein
bisschen chillen wollen dann geht es
natürlich auch einfach mal darum wer
also wer dachte dass es gerade im
schonraum war das unser bruder mit dem
hero blütenbad leider nicht auf platz
eins gekommen ist der wird jetzt richtig
belohnt werden und ich glaube in der
kategorie lassen jetzt richtig die sau
raus was ist jetzt gerade gesagt hat sie
gesagt glaube ich gesagt nice to meet
you schön dich zu essen also ich muss
sagen leute bei mir drängt sich langsam
wirklich der eindruck auf dass wir es
hier mit kannibalen zu tun haben es ist
nicht anders zu erklären
daneben war schon die rede von
frischfleisch für mich schon gefragt
habe warum labor von verspricht alter
wir sind bei dir los jetzt redet sie
davon dass ich schön findet die männer
zu essen
naja ok
[Musik]
aber seine mutter sieht das alter ja ja
also du hast sich auf platz 3 gestellt
von den knackigen hintern hier bei
unserer wunderschönen sendung hat fünf
wir müssen leider sagen dass das noch
nicht so knackig wie wir uns das
vorstellen
kleine runde drei die sensibilität
auch hier müssen die männer zuerst ihre
eigene reihenfolge ausfechten auf zum
kampf okay sensibilität jetzt also ich
glaube das ist jetzt der punkt wo sie
tatsächlich die jungs aber beleidigen
und gucken wir zuerst weint oder willst
du als irgendwie immer zueinander
reaktion zeigt also die kategorisiert
nicht kompletter müll also die stellen
die jungs dahin ja die jungs stehen in
badehose deine reihe und dann bewusst
die frauen jury hier anhand des
aussehens wie sensibel die jungs sind
das ist natürlich sehr sinnvoll also bei
dem denke ich mir der hat zwar muskel
aber der könnte trotzdem sensibel sein
weil eigentlich geht es ja nicht
und du wir sind sie beste harte schale
weicher kern
ich muss schon sagen dass ich auch sehr
sensibel bin und die jury hat leider
komplett daneben gelegen was die jury
hat komplett daneben gelegen
unfassbar einfach weniger
ich kann es gar nicht glauben die
kommentare die herausgabe kommentar von
benjamin väter die in den blauen kleid
sieht aus wie ganz klar sagen dass diese
aussage jetzt so nicht unterschreiben
würde aber das outfit
jetzt können die männer stil und
geschmack unter beweis stellen okay das
wird auch interessant also weil diese
art von ja schauen wir also wirklich
einem anderen jahrtausend gedreht wurden
die klamotten oder auf die haare die
frisuren der wie das aussieht das sieht
aus also mindestens wellen überhaupt
gerade so im jahr 2003 2004 gedreht oder
so klasse definitiv also stichwort tony
montana
hey was labbadia gros der junge trägt
ein gelbes hemd also ein gelbes jungen
der sich aus biene maja wo ist das ein
guter stil
und was hat das mit tony montana zu tun
ok muss man dazu sagen da muss ich ihn
wirklich recht geben also an alle jungs
da draußen tut mir den gefallen falls es
schon gemacht habe kein problem aber
trat er in zukunft keine kurzen hemden
mehr wirklich kurzarmhemden sind
absoluter reinfall
haben sie okay dann biete maja auf platz
2 gewartet
ich glaube vielmehr müssen wir zum mode
geschmack von diesen frauen an der
stelle wirklich nicht sagen
er hat jetzt schon mal gewonnen hier
willi hat gewonnen aber ich habe mir
gerne in die kommentare was ihr davon
haltet ihr das weniger schlimm als die
folge mit den frauen ich muss persönlich
sagen ich fand sich ganz so schlimm aber
scheint mir gerne eure meinung unten
rein klickt ihr einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das video leute hier oben
könnt ihr einen kanal abonnieren ich
will an der stelle raus ich kann nur so
viel sagen
die ägyptischen roten bart lasst die
gelben hemden auf jeden fall an und
macht es gut meint es sei
zu youtube